[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans le
grand studio du figaro on est en direct
on est avec vous ces filières alive et
on attend vos points de vue vos
réactions après l'incident en milieu de
journée de tain l'hermitage emmanuel
macron giflé lors d'un bain de foule
on y revient ce soir avec alexis brézet
bonsoir alexis directeur des rédactions
du figaro est avec vous avec nous ce
soir pascal perrineau
bonsoir pascal plancque auteurs
dernièrement d'un que cet opus sur le
populisme à lire bien entendu on y
reviendra peut-être dans l'actualité
aussi ce soir le débat sur l'extension
de la pma pour les coupes de femmes et
enfin selon vous il faut faut-il
relancer la réforme des retraites avant
la fin du quinquennat
pour l'instant vous n'êtes pas trop
favorable les votes sont encore ouverts
et le débat aussi en fin d'émission à
balma cronie voilà ce qu'à crier
l'auteur de l'agression contre les
manuels macron la scène vous la voyez
c'est passé à midi lors de la visite du
chef de l'état à tain l'hermitage dans
la drôme à la sortie du lycée hôtelier
où se trouve emmanuel macron l'entourage
du chef de l'état a ensuite confirmé la
scène qui a tourné en boucle sur twitter
peut-être une réaction un commentaire
pascal c'est pas la première fois que le
chef de l'état emmanuel macron est prise
à partie ce n'est pas la première fois
qu'un chef de de l'état est agressée est
ce que c'est un acte de votre point de
vue isolé l'acte du fou un classique en
tous les cas craint par les services de
sécurité ou quelque chose de plus il
faut espérer que c'est un acte isolé
personne ne peut se réjouir de voir le
président de la république celui qui
symbolise l'unité du pays
giflé par un quidam cependant au delà
de l'aspect peut-être exceptionnel parce
qu'on va apprendre certainement sur ceux
d'amiens qui a été arrêté son compère on
va voir si ce sont des militants
éventuellement des militants monarchiste
égaré certains disent ils sont dans la
mouvance des gilet jaune bien au delà de
cet itinéraire personnel
on sent bien dans la société française
qui lie à une montée de la violence
violence des actes violences des
comportements violence symbolique la
violence des mots il y à un relâchement
même on le voit du discours politique
par nombre d'acteurs qu'il soit de
l'extrême gauche de la droite de la
droite même de l air m
on voit en effet un relâchement des
moeurs politiques qui fait que pour
certains des tabous sont tombés et qu'on
peut passer on peut signifier son rejet
non pas dans un débat mais on peut
signifier son rejet par un passage à
l'acte
ce à quoi on a ainsi insisté dans ce
paisible département département de la
drôme et je crois aussi qu'il y a le
fait que quand on est dans un contexte
où les divergences politiques n'arrivent
plus à s'exprimer au travers
j'allais dire de point de vue chargé de
sens
éventuellement de référents idéologiques
il ne reste plus que quoi dans le
paysage politique
il ne reste plus que les personnes et
donc on s'en prend aux personnes et on a
vu monter dans le mouvement des gilet
jaune une hostilité au président de la
république tout à fait particulière ce
jeune président qui au début était voilà
ou bien susciter l'indifférence ou bien
était plus ou moins aimé parce qu'il
était jeune il était nouveau dans le
paysage très vite va se fixer sur lui
une hostilité qui n'a pas beaucoup de
contenu idéologique pour les gens c'est
une hostilité vis-à-vis de la personne
vis-à-vis de ce qu'il est de ce qu'il
représente
vis-à-vis même de très physique par
moments et moi je crains beaucoup que le
débat politique et dieu sait s'il va y
avoir un débat avec les régionales et
départementales puis la présidentielle
laisse beaucoup trop de place à ces
systèmes d'affect débridée et non
contrôlée avec 6 c'est également le
casse-tête pour une macro soit il est
protégé et isolé s'esquisser la critique
qui est fait quand il est à
saint-cirq-lapopie soit il va au contact
et là il risque selon en attaque
c'est le casse-tête de tous les hommes
politiques tous les présidents de tous
les hommes publics et entre l' isolement
et la trop grande proximité
jusqu'à présent les présidents de la
république
ce sont comme souvent affranchi des
règles trop strictes pour aller serrer
des mains et jusqu'à présent ça c'était
quand même plutôt pas trop mal passé il
ya une fois chirac s'était fait un peu
cracher dessus mais au milieu d'une
foule qui était très favorable
sarkozyste est un peu fait agiter
hollande dans mon souvenir c'était un
jour de la farine ma distance sa fille
c'est la première fois qu'ils à ce geste
dans d'autres temps dire de lèse majesté
en fait ce geste là tantôt d'accord il
ya quelque chose de très symbolique de
très violents le très brutal
extrêmement choquant et pour te dire de
navan pour l'étape du débat dans ce pays
et c'est absolument vrai alors on va
voir effectivement qui sont le gaou les
deux gars parce qu'apparemment on
arrêtait deux il semblerait d'après ce
que dit notre journaliste qui suit la
question que ce soit des plus tôt des
gens de nouveau et gilet jaune sarr
couperet alors là c'est tout ce climat
effectivement docilité très fort que le
gilet jaune entretenu contre la personne
de macron que le slogan montjoie saint
denis qui était enfin l'heure serait
paraît-il mais je dis ça c'est avec
toute réserve
un des slogans qui a utilisé par les
gilet jaune qui n'aurait rien à voir
avec une question monarchiste mais
plutôt avec les visiteurs jeudi c'est
comme on me l'a dit mais mais mais c'est
peut-être vrai après c'est vrai qu'il ya
quelque chose de paradoxal de ce pays où
finalement on refuse le conflit
notamment le conflit idéologique odiah
plus droite ya plus de gauche le débat
d'idées il faut prendre beaucoup de
précautions pour ne pas blesser les gens
qui ont exprimé vis-à-vis des clients
des fouines telle ou telle opinion on
passe le temps à avoir des minorités qui
ciblent blessés par des mots jamais le
débat public n'a été aussi
précautionneux dans les mots jamais on a
pris des précautions sont passés à un
film disney on met des des
avertissements ou le l'attention les
aristochats peut-être que ça serait
méchant et en même temps on voit et
c'est ainsi dans la grave on est calme
manifestation parmi d'autres une montée
de la violence directe de l'alliance
brutale de la violence finalement la
plus irrationnelle et la plus brute
c'est vrai que c'est quelque chose
d'inquiétant c'est une prophétie
également qu'on a pu voir au cinéma dans
cette série de canal puis ce dont je
vais essayer de retrouver le nom qui
n'est pas le bureau des légendes mais
qui est l'autre et qui est baron noir
voilà mercier marier mais on voit
justement une scène d'agression
comme cela est exactement comme ça et là
on est dans dans le film la thèse du
film c'est que c'est effectivement une
expression de de ce populisme mais sans
corpus idéologique bien sûr quand il
n'ya plus le choc des mots le débat
autour des monts où on reconnaît l'autre
comme un adversaire plus que comme un
ennemi et bien quand il ya plus ce choc
des mots il ya des passages à l'acte et
l'autre en pas en politique n'est plus
et un adversaire il devient un ennemi un
ennemi à abattre un ennemi que l'on peut
agresser physiquement comme le président
mâcon vient d'être agressés physiquement
et on voit très bien que ces tensions
vont être difficiles à faire retomber
parce que l'affrontement ne trouve plus
de cadres pour s'exprimer en france les
partis ont quasi disparu
les idéologies on nous dit qu'il faut
remiser sa au magasin des accessoires et
on n'arrive plus à parler puisque il y a
des idées qui sont considérées comme
tellement incorrect voilà il ya le
politiquement correct
donc on ne peut plus abordés j'allais
dire de manière calme et franche et
sereine autour d'une table le débat
politique
donc voilà qu'est ce qui reste eh bien
les points les mains et c'est dramatique
j'ajouterai que dès lors qu'on observe
dans tous les secteurs de la vie de tous
les jours la montée de la violence la
violence directe on parle beaucoup des
agressions continues toutes les formes
d'autorité les policiers les les
professeurs les pompiers etc
et ça on le voit tous les jours et
personne ne peut le contester compris
dans les statistiques on le voit en ce
moment que le nombre d'agressions contre
les détenteurs d'autres étaient de plus
en plus élevés finalement qu'à que le
louise ou en tout cas de ce processus se
manifeste aussi parlé d'agression de
plus en république ce désastreux mais il
ya quelque chose de finalement tout
cohérent avec lille une évolution qu'on
est en train de vivre
il ya le respect
vite des autorités qu'elles soient y
compris l'autorité suprême qui est ça le
rendra public
ce respect là n'est plus du tout ce
qu'il était nicole no17 vidéo circule
partout même à l'étranger quelle va être
la perception de demande-t-elle en tout
cas ce qu'ont ce qu'on a pu voir déjà
cet après midi c'est que les
condamnations ont été unanimes alors à
l'assemblée jean castex a appelé au
sursaut républicain condamnations y
compris chez les opposants les plus
farouches du chef de l'état je vous
propose de voir deux réactions d'abord
marine le pen qui est en conférence de
presse où se trouvait notre confrère du
figaro charles sympa qui a pris cette
vidéo
les responsables politiques et plus
encore plus encore au président live
parce qu'il est le président et vous
voyez moi j'ai évidemment vous le savez
je suis la première opposante à emmanuel
macron mais il est le président de la
république et à ce titre on peut le
combattre politiquement mais on ne peut
pas se permettre d'avoir à son égard le
moindre geste
le la moindre violence je considère que
c'est ce comportement est inadmissible
et profondément profondément condamnable
autre réaction très rapide également de
jean luc mélenchon sur twitter alors
jean luc mélenchon lui en a profité pour
dire cette fois si vous commencez à
comprendre que les violents passe à
l'acte je suis solidaire du président
calé comment vous analysé la réaction de
marine le pen et jean luc mélenchon
parce qu'à écouter c'est la moindre des
choses que les responsables des deux
principales l'opposition on va voir
comment l air également réagi ainsi que
les socialistes puisqu'il faut pas
parler d'une opposition mais de
plusieurs oppositions en france précise
qu'il y a des règles du débat
démocratique et que parmi ces règles du
débat démocratique il ya le refus de
tout mode d'agression physique on a déjà
suffisamment d'agressions verbales jour
et nuit
on va pas y rajouter maintenant
l'agression physique donc il ya là une
position extrêmement responsable je ne
suis pas sûr en revanche que le fait que
jean luc mélenchon mentionnent ils
auraient pu se contenter de condamner ce
qu'il fait dans la deuxième partie de
son tweet qu'il met ça dans la montée
générale des violences dont il parlait
et qui devrait encombré selon lui les
deux tours de l'élection présidentielle
ça c'est une autre affaire il ya un
mélange des genres qui nuit à la pureté
de la leçon qu'il veut donner sinon pas
grand chose à ajouter c'est un réflexe
naturel
je pense que ça il faut pas toutes
analysées en termes de stratégie
évidemment si man de peines le fait avec
cette solennité c'est qu'elle a décidé
de le faire vous avez été associé un
message qu'elle envoie mais partout
c'est un mot ce message éminemment
respectable jeu mariage comment dire je
pense qu'il y assez moment où les
responsables politiques disent ce qu'ils
pensent ils sont choqués ne serait ce
que parce qu'ils se disent que peut-être
un jour ça peut leur arriver et et puis
quand même au delà des affaires
politiques à sombre de règles qui fait
que des gens de même qu'ils sont en
absolu des accords peuvent se retrouver
sur singles n'y a pas lieu à épiloguer
très lentement sur là dessus c'est la
moindre des choses il fallait faire
c'est fait c'est très bien voilà donc et
kris kross nous demande aux états unis
les services secrets sont sur les dents
protège ton assez le président en france
c'est un débat sur lequel on va revenir
dans les prochaines heures et vous
pourrez lire tout ce qu'il ya sur cette
question dans le figaro pendant ce temps
les débats reprennent parlement dernière
lecture pour le projet de loi bioéthique
et en particulier la mesure phare
l'extension de la pma aux couples de
femmes et les débats reste polarisée
du côté du gouvernement notamment le
ministre de la santé olivier vers ans
qui a vanté l'article qui instant tu qui
institue l'extension de la pma et qui
appelle à une promulgation rapide par
cet article et la famille française ça
grandit dans la diversité de ses modèles
et dans la richesse de ces
configurations
c'est un enjeu d'égalité les textes
d'application de la loi ils doivent être
préparés dès à présent pour pouvoir être
publiée immédiatement après la
promulgation de la loi afin que des
couples de femmes puissent s'inscrire
dans des parcours de pmad la rentrée et
que deux premiers enfants puissent être
conçues avant la fin de l'année 2021
c'est à dire mesdames et messieurs les
députés que nous y sommes enfin en face
le républicain à bruno retailleau qui
avait mené la fronde au sénat qui a
justement remis en cause la la première
lecture à l'assemblée campe sur ses
positions et lens l'alertent tant qu'on
aura pas prouvé que pour un enfant
l'absence d'un père est sans conséquence
je préfère la prudence
il ya aussi une autre raison je ne vois
pas à partir du moment où on va accorder
aux femmes cette possibilité au nom de
quoi on pourrait refuser la même
possibilité par la gpa la gestation pour
autrui aux hommes
alexis est ce que le gouvernement et
vindelle macron pouvez reporter
la discussion sans risque de se voir
accuser de ne pas réaliser une promesse
phare c'était un risque mais en même
temps là il va se retrouver en butte à
l'accusation de s'être précipitées
c'est vrai que la façon dont verrons
nous dit il faut le faire dès à présent
il faut immédiatement
il faut dès la rentrée afin que des
enfants des soins 2020 mais pourquoi fin
du livre demain et pas des bus 2022 ou
fin 2022 enfin on a l'impression que
tout à coup une urgence sur cette
affaire qui est curieuse sachant que
cette cette question de la pma eux est
loin de faire consensus sur le voit on
l'a vu lors des états généraux qui
avaient eu lieu il y avait la bioéthique
qui sur la bioéthique avait conclu à
lieux dont la communauté qu'il fallait
pas le faire
on loue également décidé de le faire
quand même la suite des discussions au
sénat où le sait les sénateurs on avait
des faits absolument la proposition
telle qu'elle avait faim la projette
qu'il avait été voté au parlement
on revient au forceps au projet initial
en oubliant tout ce qu'a fait le sénat
il ya un certain nombre d'études
d'opinion qui disent que les gens après
ils sont divisés sur cette question de
la pma eux mais en tout cas personne ne
considère que ce soit une priorité il ya
mille autres choses à faire il ya la
pandémie et la croissance ya le chômage
et l'insécurité
je trouve qu'une espèce de
d'empressement à cocher la case pour
dire on l'a fait on l'a fait qui vu la
gravité de l'enjeu on peut être pourrait
on peut être contre je trouve que vous
par rapport à la gravité de l'enjeu qui
représente une question se dépêcher de
faire quasiment la sauvette avec 12
heures de débats
pour cette question de la da pena puis
d'autres qui sont pas pas négligeable
non plus il ya un empressement qui moi
me paraît critiquable pascal plus
personne ne s'intéresse à la pma
actuellement c'est pas moi qui le dis
assez didier sicard ce matin dans le
figaro
seuls ceux qui ont proposé cette réforme
que perdre emmanuel macron à ne pas
faire sont très forts alors vous savez
le problème c'est qu'elle sera pour le
président le bilan et le bilan est
relativement mince
parce que aussi c'est un président qui a
été confronté à de multiples crises
crise économique crise sociale prise des
gilets jaunes crise sanitaire je ne dis
pas qu'un autre président aurait mieux
fait
pendant pendant ces quatre ans et donc
il a besoin maintenant comme alexis
viens de le dire de cocher des cases en
disant 'vous voyez pour tous et en
particulier des électeurs qui votent de
manière rétrospective comme on dit en
regardant le bilan 1 pour qu'on n'ait
pas l'impression pour faire grossir un
peu l'aspect des promesses tenues
vous pensez que ça permet de mobiliser
son électorat une partie de son élan je
ne crois pas moi je ne crois pas parce
que comme vous le dites comme didier
sicard le dis les gens n'ont pas du tout
cela en tête
et d'autre part je ferai remarquer qu'
il y a plus en plus sur la scène
politique des débats autour des valeurs
autour de réformes qui touchent à la
manière de vivre ensemble au couple à la
notion que l'on a de la famille
et ces débats ne peuvent pas être bâclé
ils l'ont déjà été au moment de la loi
taubira à souvenez-vous ça les
consultations étaient des consultations
extrêmement active en particulier les
consultations des groupes de pensée des
forces spirituelles tout ça était traité
par dessus la jambe
je crois que ces sujets qui sont des
sujets sociétaux mérites du temps le
temps de la réflexion le temps de la
consultation
et il faut savoir que si on ne le fait
pas on va aviver ce que je pourrais
appeler presque des guerres culturelles
et on commence dans nos pays à rentrer
de plus en plus dans des affrontements
guerre est un peu excessif mais dans des
affrontements culturel dont la société
française en ce moment n'a vraiment pas
besoin il faut savoir en effet on peut
être pour
on peut être contre mais qu'il y a eu
des mobilisations et de mobilisation
significative alors il est vrai qu'en
termes de sondages mais il faut faire
attention en termes de sondages c'est
une majorité maintenant de français
large qui est pour la pema pour toute la
gpa ça ça devient beaucoup plus
compliqué mais comme le disait le
sénateur retailleau la crainte de tout
une particule en particulier de la
droite sénatoriale c'est de dire mais
après la paix mayorat la gpa et donc ça
n'est que la porte ouverte à la gpa
sachant que oui on dit
ya des pays dans lequel il ya une pma
qui est ouverte pour toutes les portes
toutes les femmes et pas simplement pour
les femmes ce qu'elles cas aujourd'hui
pour les couples infertiles ou pour les
situations où il y à un danger pour
avoir un enfant pour des raisons de
maladie génétique ou autre ça c'est la
situation actuelle mais il faut savoir
que par exemple des pays comme la
belgique bon je ne crois pas qu'ils
aient la gpa en belgique je me trompe
peut-être mais je ne crois pas donc il
ya des pays dans lequel il y a voyez des
pma mais on sait très bien que de la
manière dont le débat est posé et quand
on écoute tout de même olivier ferrand
qui nous vante alors il y allait en
effet le timing il faudrait y aller très
très vite
attention réfléchissons et puis il ya
aussi il vante la richesse des modèles
familiaux mais qu'est ce que ça veut
dire ça veut dire qu'on va vers alors il
ya de nombreuses éclatement je le sais
aujourd'hui on parle beaucoup
d'éclatement politique il ya des
éclatements sociaux des éclatements
culturel qu'est ce que c'est que cet
éclatement de la structure familiale
quand anton exactement par cela quelle
est la richesse des modèles il faut il
ya peut-être d'autres modèles que le
modèle papa moment m'enfin bon voilà mes
jeux
il faudrait qu'on nous prouve que ce
sont des modèles riche voiliers et non
pas des modèles traumatisant pour celui
qui est principalement concerné par tout
ça c'est à dire l'enfant est en tout cas
l'enchaînement vers la gpa c'est vrai
que l'argument selon lequel le droit
puisque si d'un droit qu'on accorde aux
couples de femmes c'est très difficile
de le refuser aux couples d'hommes sur
quels motifs sûr qu'elles font danser
comme compliquée et qu'en tout cas que
cette crainte soit partagé par une large
partie de l'opinion peut le comprendre
regard du passé les gens qu'à me
souvenir qu'on leur a dit on va faire le
pacs mais ne vous inquiétez pas on fait
le pas ce qu'il y aura pas de mariage
homosexuel puis après on a fait des
mariages homosexuels des fêtes mariages
hausse qu'elle ne vous inquiétez pas
vraiment un jeu sans adoption qui on a
fait l'adoption le dire d'accord on fait
l'adoption mais ne vous inquiétez pas il
n'y a pas de paiement et puis on fait la
paix maintenant on dit vous inquiétez
pas il aura pas de gp à personne n'y
croit tous les gens voient bien que que
chaque étape appel l'étape suivante
j'ajoute que dans cette fois chose dont
on parle peu mais quand même qu'ils sont
qu elle il faudrait s'arrêter
il n'y a pas que la pma et se rassemble
d'autres dispositions
qui n'ont l'air d'intéresser personnes
parmi lesquelles la création de chimères
d'espèces de travaux sur l'animal et
l'homme pour des raisons médicales
enfin quand on voit ce qui se passe en
ce moment on se dit est ce que c'est
vraiment s'il formidable que ça les
soirs de l'exploitation des cellules
souches embryonnaires qui pose un
certain nombre de problèmes éthiques
et pas que pour les religions l'auto
conservation des ovocytes des ovocytes
permettre de faire des enfants à tout
âge
est-ce que ça pose pas aussi ensemble de
problèmes de société la question
laquelle l'âge on fait des enfants
enfin bref je crois il semblerait qu'on
ait échappé à liège et l'interruption
médicale de grossesse à neuf mois c'est
déjà ça encore que faut être sûr que les
parlementaires ne remettront pas dans la
sphère mais enfin il ya tout un tas de
dispositions comptes dont on est en
train de nous dire allez allez dépêchez
vous dépêchez vous parce que le
gouvernement le président veut cocher
une case
je comprends très bien que madame
accrocher des cases sur son programme et
enfin on parle quand même d'enfants de
père de mère de la vie de la mort c'est
des sujets qui méritent peut-être un peu
davantage que de cocher des cases sans
attenter accès demande et c'est une
question qu'on entend poser en tous les
cas depuis depuis la réouverture de ce
débat est ce qu'il ne faudrait pas faire
mal sur ce sujet ce qui permettrait de
relancer ce débat un débat que oui mais
un référendum pourquoi pas je n'ai pas
de je considère d un jour toute façon il
va bien falloir rétablir des référendums
sur des sujets sur lequel ben voilà il
est peut-être bon de consulter les
français surtout quand ils sont touchés
dans leur vie je les dirai jusque dans
leur vie intime alors vie familiale
leurs rapports avec les enfants avec
leurs conjoints etc ou leur conjointe
donc pourquoi pas mais à condition qu'il
y ait en amont affrété pas et il n'y a
pas de véritable arrivée quand même
grave un consensus est autant il ya des
sujets on peut trancher la minorité la
majorité la cmc des sujets où l'idéal
est quand même d'essayer d'arriver à ce
qu'un consensus et le consensus il se
construit progressivement et ça que le
référendum est un peu comme large larmes
qui permet à 51% gagné contre 49 en
l'occurrence
de l'assemblée c'est exactement la même
chose qui va se passer puisque les
députés en marche à quelques exceptions
près ont voté comme un seul homme ou une
seule femme ce texte de loi et que les
autres roncq a circulé mais c'est vrai
qu'on pourrait se dire que alors qu'on
nous parle tout le temps de dialogue de
choses que de co-construction de démodé
que daho mocratie participation voilà
c'est tout le contraire vous pouvoir
c'est quand même curieux il mêle
démocratie participative sur ce sujet
moi je l'attends avec les forces les
grandes forces représentatives des
courants d'idées des les différentes
religions parce que je regardais avant
de venir les données de sondage
alors c'est très intéressant pour il
n'est pas très étonnant que les gens de
plus de 65 ans ne sont pas favorables à
l'extension de la pma à tout mais vous
avez par exemple les musulmans les
protestants les catholiques sont assez
partagés mais vous avez voyez on voit
bien des gens qui du fait de leur
système de croyances se disent voilà il
faut pas aller trop vite en besogne
avant de faire sauter les structures
familiales fondamental dans lesquels nos
valeurs personnelles et religieuses sont
investis faut pas aller trop vite en
besoin donc donnons-nous le temps
organisons de véritables débats afin
d'arriver à ce que alexis brézet pour
appeler un compromis moral mais aussi un
compromis moral selon vous l'ouverture
de la pma aux couples de femmes de
talent être une priorité en fin de
quinquennat et vous étiez une large
majorité à répondre non à 75% autres
questions qu'on pose sur twitter faut-il
relancer la réforme des retraites
également avant la fin du quinquennat
voici alors il ya un débat en tout cas
une pression et si vous avez lu dans le
figaro ce matin
hier par dans une pression sur le dans
l'entourage du chef de l'état pour
relancer le débat
voici notamment ce qu'en disait
elisabeth bornes ces derniers jours
enfin moi je vous dis je pense que la
crise elle n'a rien retiré à la
pertinence d'une réforme des retraites
on a 42 régime dans lequel finalement ça
donne très peu de lisibilité on sait
qu'on s'est finie l'époque où on faisait
toute sa carrière dans la même
entreprise
du coup ça a créé beaucoup de complexité
pour les français paient beaucoup
d'injustices donc c'est des sujets
effectivement sur lesquels il faut
réfléchir et on verra en fonction de
l'état du pays quelles réformes dans
quel calendrier donc je vais pas vous
répondre puisque président de la
république y réfléchit alors le
président de la république y réfléchit
et il s'est exprimé justement ce matin
sur la question avant l'incident de la
chiffrés à horizon des années à venir
le sujet des retraites existent pour
notre pays est ce que c'est la priorité
du moment est ce que c'est ce que est ce
que c'est mon objectif de cette semaine
non tous les débats sont légitimes ils
viendront en temps voulu alexis ils me
disent ah bon moi ça me confirme que
tout dans l'idée qu'il ne le fera pas
alors qu'il faut pas le faire après ce
qu'on a compris là on voit qu'il est
dehors et isabelle borne à côté de la
plaque
c'est qu'il ya une chose qu'il ne fera
pas que la région peut faire c'est la
fameuse réforme systémique dans une zone
du noir depuis les oreilles pendant des
mois et des mois que personne n'a rien
compris donc système de 6,2 de retraite
à points censée simplifier cette affaire
tellement simple que même les ministres
arrivaient pas à l'expliquer donc sa
macro dix ans le fera pas donc
maintenant la question et fera t-on la
réforme nécessaire d'un point de vue et
financier économique et de dire aux
français mais il faut travailler
davantage en angleterre l'âge de départ
est de 66 ans en allemagne il est de 65
ans et huit mois
donc il faut vous partiez plus tard
chose qui est nécessaire d'un point de
vue
financiers pour l'équilibré des régimes
important d'un point de vue économique
notamment comme message vis-à-vis de
l'europe sur le thème parce qu'on sent
bien qu'elle commençait par des tensions
sur les marchés
vu la quantité de dettes qu'on apprend
d'accumuler donc comme manifestation
d'une volonté de réformer ce qui
permettrait au passage d'ailleurs à
emmanuel macron de cocher une case
puisqu'il a tellement envie de cocher
des cases et pourrait cocher celle là
donc ça c'est les aspects du plus de la
nécessité de les faire après le risque
évidemment c'est de mettre les français
dans la rue notamment des syndicats
c'est vrai que cette question de l'âge
pour nécessaire qu'elle soit et le
chiffon rouge pour les syndicats y
compris de la cfdt qui est le plus
modéré d'entre eux et qu'ils considèrent
que ce serait une trahison absolue donc
la marque quand il devra quelque chose
de difficile qui se dira je fais une
réforme nécessaire qui me permettrait
d'inscrire sa mon bilan
mais si j'avais vraiment présidentielle
et que je bloque tout le pays à la
veille de la présidentielle et que au
passage de riscle aussi de mettre en
péril le redémarrage de l'économie parce
que si l'économie serait arrête en
octobre novembre décembre s'est pas non
plus formidable donc c'est légitime
qu'il hésite vu cette phrase à j'ai
l'impression que c'est pas demain la
veille qu'on le fera mais je peux me
tromper parce qu'elle est ce que il ya
une réforme qui pourrait être acceptée
par l'opinion
aujourd'hui mais là aussi ça renvoie un
peu aux débats précédents il faut se
donner un petit peu de temps il faut
discuter on cite souvent le cas suédois
mais le cas suédois c'est ma mémoire est
bonne il avait dû commencer dans les
années 90 1
ça a pris de très nombreuses années pour
arriver à un compromis qui aujourd'hui
est un compromis qui marche
mais attention le compromis était déjà
une interview et il était plus facile
hier qu'aujourd'hui pourquoi parce que
les comptes publics se sont énormément
dégrader et que maintenant les
compensations que l'on pourrait donner
aux perdants de la réforme
ces compensations elles vont être très
difficiles à dégager donc ça va être à
la limite une réforme plus dur
une réforme plus dur sachant qu'en effet
il ne faut pas une réforme systémique
faut en effet toiletter les régimes
sociaux faut rapprocher les régimes
public et les régimes privés afin
d'introduire un peu plus de justice
comme dit madame bornes dans le
dans le système des retraites mais il
faudra pas aller au delà il faudra bien
trouver une réponse à la question
comment compenser les perdants de la
réforme dans un contexte de deux comptes
publics extrêmement dégradée alors c'est
justement l'argument qui est donné c'est
que là on va avoir une roland il y
aurait une relance assez forte
par effet de rattrapage et que ce serait
c'est en tout cas l'argument de bruno le
maire de profiter de cet effet de blast
sur l'économie pour pouvoir faire cette
réforme est ce que si c'était le cas est
ce que ça pourrait être là justement cet
argument oui mais vous avez fait déjà vu
la mobilisation qui était pas
négligeable du mouvement syndical dans
sa diversité
vous imaginez dans le temps très bref
qui va être septembre la 2021 voilà si
on a des manifestations qui commence à
l'est au mois d'octobre et qui perdure
jusqu'au mois de février vous allez
casser le mouvement de relance et la
présidentielle va se développer à
nouveau dans un contexte chaotique où
les français ont la pression qu après le
chaos de lakovic 19 il ya le chaos du la
réforme des retraites
je veux dire c'est peut-être pas d'une
grande habileté politique alors sera un
avantage politique pour macro ce serait
mettre l'île de la droite dans la panade
choses auxquelles ils assez sensible
s'il aime bien ça et donc c'est sûr
qu'une telle réforme la droite voudrait
obliger de la soutenir surfaces ont été
jugés totalement c'est quand même
compliqué quand on est de droite s'il
réforme c'est bien de dire faut
travailler plus longtemps c'est
compliqué en ordre ne faut pas
travailler plus longtemps c'est vraiment
pas la peine c'est pas le moment il donc
ça serait compliqué de ne pas soutenir
macro et donc dans la pratique de la
présidentielle ça peut avoir un avantage
pour macron autre avantage fort macron
jeu c'est de voir les deux côtés de la
faire autre avantage de la con ça peut
être aussi de choisir le terrain de
l'affrontement
c'est qu'au fond il crée son clivage ci
mais cet objet qu'elle informe des
retraites au milieu mais il re clive il
ya tous ceux qui seront pour en gros la
droite
le centre ce qui se rencontrent la
gauche aurait pu beaucoup et le front
national qui vivent et donc il prend
l'initiative plutôt que d'attendre
d'aller jusqu'à la présidentielle
petitement en louvoyant risquant de se
prendre des paquets de mer dans un sens
dans l'autre venus d'ici venue de là il
peut dire je crée la grande bataille
je suis le chef de guerre bon ça tout ça
c'est vrai sur le papier la réalité sur
la rue disait pascal s'est bloqué le
pays en octobre novembre décembre à
refaire une jupe et à trois mois d'une
présidence ou quatre mois d'une escale
c'est quand même c'est quand même très
très risqué c'est pour ça que moi je
crains un autre scénario qui est que on
nous met tout ça sur la table pour dire
on va le faire
on va pas le faire tout de suite alors
ce qu'on va faire tout de suite c'est
qu'on va faire des allocations pour les
jeunes parce que ça nous traiteraient
besoin puis ça c'est pas politiquement
c'est facile
et puis on va aussi créer un régime
dépendance parce que c'est très
nécessaire on n'a pas le moindre sou
pour le payer mais c'est pas grave
et tout ça on le financera demain avec
les économies futures qui sont rapportés
par la réforme éventuelle des retraites
qu'il faut absolument faire là on peut
avoir ce scénario là mais tout en disant
mais on a commencé à faire la réforme
des retraites parce qu'on a le comité
théodule la comité de consultation alors
là on fera de la consultation pour
gagner du temps
je sens sinon je ne comprendrais pas
pourquoi il met ça sur le tapis
si c'est pour ne rien faire pourquoi en
parler alors c'est lui qui a commencé à
en parler donc s'il en parle
mon sentiment que c'est de la pure
analyse ces deux c'est que c'est qu'il
va utiliser ça pour commencer à dire le
jeu je le ferai quand je serai réélu
donc je voyais je vous dis les choses
ainsi s'ils voulaient me enfin et en
attendant on va faire des trucs pour les
jeunes des trucs pour les vieux comme
comme ça voulait comme je suis gentil
mais pourquoi
macron n'at-il pas fait cette réforme
dès 2017 nous demande chris coste alors
un trône at il l'a fait et il ya eu de
la contestation et puis c deja celle là
c'était la réforme systémique et tommy
dont il nous expliquait qu'il fallait
surtout pas qu'elles conduisent à
travailler les gens plus longtemps et
donc les indiens mais alors pourquoi
s'embêter à faire une réforme si à la
fin des régimes de retraite sont dans le
même état financier n'a pas de sens
parce que madame bornes parlait en effet
de l'illisibilité jusque est vrai que
des quarante deux régimes de retraite
mais lisibilité de la réforme était à la
hauteur de visibilité selon vous faut-il
relancer la réforme des retraites avant
la fin du quinquennat et vous êtes là
vous étiez un petit peu un petit peu
moins nombreux à dire non avant le début
de l'émission vous êtes un petit peu
plus nombreux 60% merci beaucoup de nous
avoir suivis merci beaucoup d'avoir
commenté merci alexis merci pascal
d'avoir commenté avec les internautes
j'en profite pour vous signaler que
demain nous serons en direct c'est
justement là là l'ouverture des
restaurants cette fois ci en intérieur
enfin avec une jauge de 50% et nous
serons en direct à 10 heures avec
philippe etchebest qui sera en direct
avec charlotte barillon dont je vous
donne rendez vous dès demain juste après
le buzz sur fear alive et vous
retrouverez demain soir quarts demies us
pour un nouveau numéro de points de vue
à trier tir fuit en live
[Musique]